never interrupt your enemy
when he is making a mistake
courage isn't having the strength to go
on
it is going on when you don't have the
strength
in politics
stupidity is not a handicap
show me a family of readers
and i will show you the people who move
the world
history is the set of lies agreed upon
imagination governs the world
if you want a thing done well
do it yourself
nothing is more difficult and therefore
more precious
than to be able to decide
history is written by the winners
a leader is a dealer in hope
the only victories which leave no regret
are those which are gained over
ignorance
the best way to keep one's word is not
to give it
men are moved by two levers only
fear and self-interest
the world suffers a lot
not because of the violence of bad
people
but because of the silence of the good
he who fears being conquered
is sure of defeat
the reason most people fail instead of
succeed
is they trade what they want most for
what they want at the moment
ten people who speak make more noise
than ten thousand who are silent
death is nothing
but to live defeated and in glorious
is to die daily
men are more easily governed through
their vices than through their virtues
ability is of little account without
opportunity
you are not taller than me
you are longer
i abhor illusion
that is why i accept the world as it is
give a man power and you will find out
who he is
love is a foolish thing done together
throw off your worries when you throw
off your clothes at night
music is what tells us that the human
race is greater than we realize
never tell your enemy he is doing the
wrong thing
history is the version of past events
that people have decided to agree upon
the people to fear are not those who
disagree with you
but those who disagree with you and are
too cowardly to let you know
victory belongs to the most
persevering
the surest way to remain poor
is to be honest
great men are meteors designed to burn
so that earth may be lighted
glory is fleeting
but obscurity is forever
a true man hates no one
the best cure for the body is a quiet
mind
the greatest danger occurs
at the moment of victory
the only victory over love
is flight
a throne is only a bench covered with
velvet
put your iron hand in a velvet glove
i saw the crown of france laying on the
ground
so i picked it up with my sword
it requires more courage to suffer than
to die
if you wish to be a success in the world
promise everything
deliver nothing
i start out by believing the worst
there is joy in danger
to conquer a woman
one has to make her laugh
success is the most convincing talker in
the world
impossible
is the word found only in a fool's
dictionary
wise people create opportunities for
themselves and make everything possible
give me enough medals and i'll win you
any war
courage cannot be counterfeited
it is one virtue that escapes hypocrisy
war is the business of barbarians
the herd seek out the great
not for their sake but for their
influence
and the great welcome them
out of vanity
or need
what is the government
nothing unless supported by opinion
i make my battle plans from the spirit
of my sleeping soldiers
when you have an enemy in your power
deprive him of the means of ever
injuring you
there are so many laws that no one is
safe from hanging
ordinary men exercise their memory more
than their judgment
do not look for malice
where everything can be explained by
stupidity
people who do not want to feed their
army
will soon be forced to feed someone
else's
a fool has a great advantage over an
educated person
he is always pleased with himself
forgiving those who revile me
i can always put myself above them
there are two levers to control people
the first is personal gain
and the second is money
i can be either a fox or a lion
the whole secret of management is
knowing when to be one
or the other
usually the soldiers win the battle
and the general gets the honors
impossible is not french
a journalist is a street cleaner with a
pen
other people's stupidity never makes us
smart
true heroism is to be above the
misfortune of life
and the impossibility of a word from the
dictionary of fools
the art of management
is not letting people grow old at their
job
genius lies in the ability to
distinguish the difficult from the
impossible
you can make a stop during the ascent
but not during the decent
wealth is not in the possession of
treasures
but in the ability to use them
hope for your support in the form of
likes and comments
thank you for watching